let's talk about another one of your
many projects Cod you're everywhere sure
the Bojack horseman sixth and final
season you've been having a good time
ago you seem surprised
even though you literally went like oh
wow people like I remember when you were
first on the show and you mentioned you
might do this thing called Bojack
horseman and the crowd was like no boo
boo I remembered you can look this up on
YouTube a couple years ago I said I
Conan O'Brien endorsed this concept
crowd went oh and you can feel the whole
thing turn around
will it get dark sometimes yeah
[Laughter]
I love that you have to keep saying I
Conan O'Brien
that's just how I talk I'm very happy
for you it's been a big success that
show very creative very fun it's been a
lot of fun being a boat jack horseman
I'm really I really enjoyed doing it I
enjoy how much we've the fans have
connected to it over I was just saying
on a just under if I can get real for
one second we absolutely hate it but no
be real per second no no I feel like it
might called you I was like I've been
shot you'd be like okay but still let's
do a bit yeah that's actually true you
know yeah poor whale he's dying really I
gotta get over there and get a few
singers in before we go
but anyway bodek horsemen it's been nice
that people have connected to the show
and and I really do appreciate when
people say it's meant a lot to me and
you know it's helped me talk about
certain issues that are otherwise hard
to talk about and we've covered a lot of
ground so that's been super gratifying
it's been really great fun show to do it
is coming to an end
they still exist we're not taking them
off the air yeah but it's gonna yeah
that would be a weird contract
well they're done now so they'll all be
destroyed you know your kids must you do
so many projects that are kid-friendly I
would think your kids would love this
stuff that you do you know what I mean I
mean yes impose a course button can get
dark sometimes but with all the Lego
stuff that you're doing and all the sort
of kid-friendly things it's pretty good
like my kid you know doing the Lego
masters have been so it's really really
fun show to do and these people are
really good at what they do and also the
byproduct is my kids super like it and
they come by I mean my office basically
at Lego masters has three and a half
million Lego bricks which is rad you
know so there I feel like I keep just
doing stuff to try to interest them
right like hey look come my god you know
yeah like a brick so I have three and a
half million right you know right but at
this rate I kind of started thinking
like as they get older like I'm gonna
have to start working it like a weed
Factory or something keep them into it
you know they can't even know like I'm a
pornographer now what's that
you'll see
sounds like something real expert over
here just say I got around in my day you
can also check that out on YouTube it's
been it's a light talking to your
wonderful man well I just wish you'd
shown up at my Christmas party some
pretty big heavy hitters came and you
always blow me off I don't know why that
is you came didn't you I was there yeah
pretty for that you know the amount of
time that I have to be yeah
Contreras a lovely party would you crazy
sing that yeah I was busy because I had
an important thing with my buddy mr.
DirecTV but the thing is now I'm kidding
you but I've liked it here you miss
every year you miss out on it and then
you give me some lame excuse I know I
know that you're literally half a block
away are you nothing sometimes you call
me and say I'm not gonna make it this
year and I can see you in the bushes
with a pipe with a pipe some day you'll
come to my house I know you will yeah
I'd love to
all right Bateman makes it over there
all the time
are you serious for real yeah all the
time I'm coming all right
Oh a little competitive huh no mean
cooks at my house are you no way twice a
week we must do it it's what he does now
to make money check out Lego masters
this is a fun show it airs Wednesdays at
9:00 on Fox and Will Arnett you're not a
good man you're a great man
[Applause]